the surprise announcement came in a
televised speech sunday night vladimir
zielinski suspending two of the most
powerful people in his government
just last thursday irina benedictova was
representing ukraine in the hague
coordinating with other countries over
investigations into war crimes as
ukraine's prosecutor general benedictova
has been a high profile and vocal figure
she's been front and center the other
suspended official hasn't had quite the
same profile but he does have very close
ties to zielinski himself ivan bakanov
was the head of the sbu ukraine spy
agency but he and zelensky were
childhood friends and he ran zielenski's
presidential campaign
zielinski suspended the two saying
members of their agencies are suspected
of conspiring with russia he said there
are 651 cases of alleged treason and
collaboration being investigated clearly
the russians have been
building this capability they have tried
to undermine the ukrainian government
the ukrainian state for a long time
now russia is applying a different
pressure on other european countries
this week russian gas exporter gazprom
sent out letters to several customers
declaring something called force measure
it means it won't be able to send as
much fuel as it was contracted to send
due to something out of its control it's
a sort of active god clause there is
fear russia could move to cut off
supplies completely countries are now
trying to refill storage sites before
winter and the heating season mike
armstrong global news